no idea what you're so happy world is
completely falling apart thank you
there's a shooting in Texas a volcano in
Hawaii an outbreak of Ebola in the Congo
but don't worry trump is monitoring it
all by tweet oh wait wait I'm just
getting this just in yeah I'm getting
his Twitter rulings Ebola incredible
volcano tremendous shooting whatever the
NRA was did any wonder people aren't
having kids anywhere did you see this
this week the fertility rate is at a
record low for the second straight year
the infant shortage is so bad now
airlines have to play tapes of baby
crying
and speaking of babies Trump
administration you know while they're
doing the other shitty stuff that's
getting all the headlines [ __ ] you a
million different ways announced they're
now cutting off federal funding for
clinics that provide abortions or even
refer patients to places that do
abortions that's right no money for
abortions that money has to come from
Michael Cohen I think Trump may have
skipped health class did you see he and
Bill Gates what Bill Gates at Bill Gates
met with Trump recently and he said
Trump asked him several times
if HIV was the same as HPV that's who
our president is a man who has to have
the talk at the age of 71 gates tried to
enter the question he tried to put it in
a way Trump could understand he said mr.
president HPV that's what you get for
sleeping with a pornstar
HIV that's what you get from sleeping
with Hannity
oh and and the big feather in his cap is
blowing away his Korean big deal looks
like it's falling apart Kim jong-un says
now that he will not dismantle his
nuclear weapons unless US military
threats are removed from South Korea and
Trump says his politics will not be
dictated by North Korea that's a new job
for Fox & Friends
Oh Oh trouble identifying great again
today you know why this is because China
this is so naked China invested half a
billion dollars in a trump resort
project in Indonesia and like the next
day Trump's lift sanctions on their
telecom company ZTE which is spying on
you that's why the our spy agencies are
against it I mean you can tell this one
is really shady because keeps referring
to the Chinese leader as president gene
catching
the nerve this guy has to then throw
tantrums about his being investigated
get me investigated a clean whistle like
me I mean it's the year anniversary of
the the Muller investigation and Trump
of course the greatest witch hunt in
American history of course everything is
the greatest in history well maybe it's
the greatest witch hunt in history but
it's got so far 17 indictments and five
guilty pleas if it's hunting witches
it's finding them the latest theory from
the bubble did you say that the FBI has
planted a spy in the Trump campaign no
not a spy this is just what the FBI does
for a living you know that's what they
do
Trump sorry man you have ties to the
American mob the Russian mob - Russian
hookers - the Kremlin to win great
indicted co-conspirators - [ __ ] goons
and shady lawyers and tax evaders and
fraudulent businesses and fake charities
and bribes and hearts money and porn
stars
they investigate shady people like you
it's like owning an ice cream truck and
going why are all these kids following
me all the time chasing me yes there's a
spy that's just a new reality show The
Apprentice is so old hat it's the mole
who's the mole in the white house tune
in next week you know I tell you the
mole I'm in a dysfunctional relationship
but Donald Trump the more weed I smoke
the more paranoid he gets
and then there's the royal wedding to
say I am excited would not be accurate I
already have my alarm set so I'll know
exactly when to start not giving a [ __ ]
but on the bright side the Queen finally
found a job for Charles did you say
he'll be walking Megan Markel down the
aisle because who better as a happy
marriage good luck charm Trump was not
invited to the wedding
he said that's okay not invited to the
royal wedding he said in their honor he
would continue to royally screw America
so look I don't want to be the whip like
enjoy the hell out of it tomorrow are
you gonna watch of course you are it's
gonna be great when a b-list actress
marries a man who will never be king in
a country that doesn't even matter
an event so unimportant even the
Russians aren't fixing it